by the way here's uh here's how it's
working out for all these guys on how
they're doing their
uh what do you call it their uh uh or
their remote work yeah let me take a
look at which ones i got here so
uh facebook is uh asking people to work
remotely until june 2021 so they're
gonna go another six months
apple uh said that they're not in a
hurry to return at least not for
several months working from home in 2021
amazon until june some of them some of
them obviously have to work
from work twitter is like listen you can
work from home for the rest of your life
if you want
salesforce is saying you got to return
to work august of 2021.
slack is saying remotely on a permanent
basis if they'd like
uh uh and they're also saying june
microsoft will reportedly allow 150
000 workers to work from home at least
part-time this is like a
hybrid model reid hastings is saying uh
they won't open up most unless if people
are majority of the people are
vaccinated
interesting so hastings said he hasn't
seen an upside of remote work
uh no i don't see any positive not being
able to get to get in person
particularly internationally he's a pure
negative i've been super impressed at
people's sacrifices
meaning he wants people to work from the
office stripe
is uh saying uh one time one part uh
one-time bonuses they're also kind of
following the
norm on what's taking place i don't know
i don't know about this working from
home situation here let me give you a
little perspective here and
i and i i shout out to kai for putting
together all these lists of companies
but let me tell you some of the words
that stuck out to me and then i'll give
you my opinion
here's some of the words that we're
using now when it comes to future of
work that did not exist
a year ago you know remote has been a
thing but wfh i remember what the hell
is wfh
work from home hybrid model flexible
schedule
virtual work decentralized jobs
a collaboration day like where you're
working from uh
working remotely for the uh you know
four days a week for example and then
one day a week you come in for a
collaboration yeah collaboration day a
relocation bonus where if you're going
to move
they might pay you less but they'll give
you a twenty thousand dollar relocation
boost
a bonus now we're talking we had a
conversation a couple weeks ago about
your employer might um
have the ability to make sure mandate
that you are vaccinated
but just to put it in perspective here's
a more of a macro historical
uh perspective when it comes to work so
let's talk about work life balance for a
second because i think no matter what
you do for a living
everyone strives to have a better
work-life balance if all you're doing is
working
right then your personal life suffers
and if all you're doing is kind of
chilling and
doing what a lot of people down in south
beach do and just kind of like
you know work on their tent and they're
not necessarily working and this is the
problem with
talent new york versus you know miami
per se you're not exactly going to be
getting ahead and
so just painting a picture overall of
work for
thousands of thousands of years people
worked from home
right that was their thing whether you
were a farmer or a blacksmith or you
were a tradesman
you had your uh you know farm outside
your house
and you were you lived upstairs and that
was just sort of what you did but
since the industrial revolution you know
call it 150 years ago per se
people have started to show up to the
workplace right go to the companies to
the factories
you know leaving the house it's almost
like you had a double life it's like you
would kiss
you know we've all seen the you know the
leave it to beaver type shows
where you'd kiss your kids goodbye in
the 50s all right i'm gonna go
to work this is sort of a madman type of
picture of this
but you go to work you you leave you're
out the house by eight you're back home
by six o'clock what have you
you have your work life and then you
have your home life
so what i what i like about this is now
maybe there's going to be a better
work-life balance maybe you're working
from home
you know three days a week two days a
week you're working from the office one
or two days a week i think
all in all what this is gonna enable
people to do if they can do this not
everyone's going to be able to
do this it's just have a healthier work
life balance so it'll be interesting how
it plays out
to have a more of a blended uh
happier life you know what what's up
with all this corporate space
i mean that is a lot of office space not
being used you got the companies leaving
california
you got the companies that say you don't
even have to come into the office if you
thought i mean
that's a lot i i don't get it what is
the end game with these companies
you